很多人就說我們有健保啊,為什麼要估高一點的醫療保健?
因為事實上當你退休之後,如果真的有發生比較需要醫療服務的時候,
可能健保能夠給付的不盡然是足夠的。
某處開戶做任務囉
很多人以為退休規劃是
65歲以後才需要煩惱的事
但真正關鍵的其實是
退休前的15到20年
今天我們邀請到陳彥祿教授
和我們一起談談
為什麼退休規劃一定要提前開始
以及這個階段最該需要準備的是什麼
那在節目開始之前
也不要忘記訂閱按贊開啟小鈴鐺
以免錯過最新的節目喔
那我們歡迎今天的來賓
陳彥祿教授教授好
你好很高興再次來到這邊
很多人會以為說
退休的規劃是65歲以後才需要煩惱
以您的經驗來看
最晚大概需要什麼時候一定要開始準備
好 退休規劃絕對不是65歲才開始
因為65你就退休了
所以既然是要規劃退休
一定是要越早開始越好
那但是我們人生有很多階段性的目標
所以也不可能真的非常的早
所以一般來說
譬如說你65歲退休
大概45歲
那最晚50歲我想就應該要開始
進入51歲到65歲這個階段
你會覺得財務規劃的目標和資產配置
應該從追求報酬成長性
慢慢轉向穩定的報酬嗎
51到65的話就表示還有15年嘛
所以如果你是15年的時間來
來準備你的退休金的話
我認為它也不用完全的穩定
為什麼因為15年還是有時間
能夠承擔一些風險的波動
所帶來的高獲利
假設51歲的時候
你大部分其他的這種財務的負擔都差不多了
50歲你還是可能有很高的收入
因為是大概是
應該有可能是最頂的時候
那在這種情況之下
事實上你也可以考慮
用不同更多不同面向的資產配置
就是除了你也有機會再買第二間房
那或者是換房
那你也可以去做不同的
除了股票型的商品
也可以加一點點債券型的商品
那至於還有沒有其他的
比如說衍生性商品
或者甚至有人問我這個穩定幣
這些我認為就是買的商品的種類
可以儘量是以你能夠理解的商品
就是股票你能夠理解它的邏輯是什麼
債券你能夠理解它的邏輯是什麼
那隻要你能夠理解他們的這些商品的種類的話
那事實上就可以來進行配置
成長性還是要的
那但是也許如果你有擔心
那你可以把這個稍微有一點點的比例往這個穩定報酬
就我們剛講說再進行的商品來靠攏
這也是可以的
在現金流的管理上
對準備退休的人來說
什麼樣的狀態才能讓人比較安心
晚上睡得著呢
如果是51到65中間
其實應該都還睡得著吧
唯一一個情況就是
臺灣應該比較少
但在國外常有就是
很多45歲以上的人
很容易被公司lay off
科技業就是很極好極壞嘛
好的時候就是可能都會拼很高
像美國現在那個資訊的人
其實都不容易找到工作
為什麼因為AI的關係
好AI可以代替很多人
很多這個寫program的人的工作
所以他們現在有一些這種中階的
低階的這個programmer都被layoff了
好那這種的他就是會睡不著
可是在我們的情況之下
51到65如果沒有工作的問題的話
事實上從投資的觀點來說
並沒有什麼太需要擔心的
為什麼因為你時間夠
但是如果假設你已經進入60了
相對的我就會建議你可以把一部分的資產
就是提高比較多比例的投資
在穩定型的資產上面
所以剛剛提到的債券型的商品的比例
就可以稍微往上拉昇
請問教授
醫療跟長照費用其實很難精準去估算
很多人也因此特別焦慮
您通常會建議準備到什麼程度
才算是足夠了
這個階段準備退休金啊
說真的
你還沒有辦法算到非常精準
有關你真正那種醫療的需求
非常高的時候
那我們一般在做退休金規劃的時候
我們都是先告訴大家說
先請你把你的這個需求
先準備下來
什麼意思呢
就是你想過什麼樣的日子
你想要過什麼樣的日子
你的基本的花費是什麼
然後你的社交活動
你可能會有一些娛樂啊
有一些跟朋友的社交啊
這些頻率
然後跟你這個有可能要產生的費用算出來
然後還有一些基本的
譬如說你要不要制裝啊
要不要做旅遊啊
這些要算出來
那有一個最重要的項目
就叫做醫療保健
很多人就說我們有健保啊
為什麼要估高一點的醫療保健
因為事實上當你退休之後
如果真的有發生比較需要醫療服務的時候
可能健保能夠給付的不盡然是足夠的
譬如說我舉個例子
這個是我45歲開始做退休金規劃的時候
沒有想到的
就是我沒有想到我要職涯
然後所以呢過去的這個十年內
我們陸陸續續職涯花了蠻多錢
如果我們在醫療保健上面
大家都認為靠這個健保
我想會有點太少
所以我會建議大家
把醫療保健的錢算進去
那甚至我都還會建議把管家
就是這個照護
像我是沒有子女的人
所以我在做退休金規劃的時候
我就會有一個項目
是所謂的這個housekeeping
就是看護或者是管家
就是我還活得很好的時候可能是管家
可是我需要照顧的時候就是看護
對不對
所以我就會有一筆這樣的錢
把這個都算進去的好處是
你算的寬鬆一點
那你現在要來準備的時候
你才會多準備一點
這個事情是我認為
50歲到65歲中間
你在做規劃的時候
先把可能的項目
先都全部整理出來
現在當然我們說退休金規劃的時候
我都會鼓勵大家時間算長一點
現在臺灣的平均壽命大概82歲
然後我都會說盡量算85
甚至可以算到90
然後另外一件事很重要
是要去看一下家族病史
因為有些人是很長壽的家族
長壽的家族這個時間走
就是可能要拉得更高一點
搞不好連90都不夠
還要再久一點
然後家族病史裡面
他們的譬如說癌症病史
因為我們已經在很多的報道里面都知道
有一些癌症事實上的確是有家族遺傳的基因
或者是有一些其他比較特殊的病症
然後也可以稍微觀察一下或回想一下
跟家人討論一下
爺爺奶奶當時在年紀大的時候
他們是怎麼樣子的醫療使用的模式
然後還有他們離開之前
因為有一件很傷心的事情
就是平均臥床的時間
要離開之前
臥床的時間其實時間很長
甚至是接近八年的時間
那這個當然是屬於
比較不那麼合適的
我們不希望看到的
所以呢
這就也表示一件事就是
我們如果可以更加的瞭解
我們自己的家族
那我們才能夠更妥適的去準備
當你50歲的時候在規劃
跟你真正到了60歲的時候
看到你父母親之後做的調整
甚至是你真正進入到退休的時候
它都可能會隨著改變的
但是隻要記得一件事
就是你考慮的周延性越多
那當然就會越有信心來準備這個部分
最後想請問教授
財務傳承不一定是一次性的遺產
而是長期有節奏的安排
您會怎麼建議開始思考這件事呢
這個的確是蠻重要的問題
尤其是50歲之後的人
因為你大致上可能在房產
或者是其他的資產上的配置都已經有了
那在這個時候
如果你有小孩
你的小孩也是漸漸的長大
所以很多時候父母親可能會思考
要幫小孩準備一些第一桶金
譬如說幫小孩付個頭期款
收益比較好的這個父母親
他可能會想要給小孩一個房產
所以不管是哪一種
他都會牽涉到一個財產
就是財務移轉的動作
那可能要有一個比較小心的事情
就是我們有所謂的免稅額這件事
所以如果你們每年要轉移
一部分的資產給你的小孩的話
每一個父母親
你移轉出去的每年就是244萬
不管給幾個小孩都一樣
超過的部分可能會要繳一個稅
尤其是譬如說房產的部分
那當然他的移轉的模式
也是可以百年度的
雖然是給他房產
但是也是可以百年度的
不一定說是一次性的
那當然一次性給個3000萬5000萬房子
那個稅的確要繳
最高是繳到20%的稅
所以如果我們沒有先行做規劃
等到這個離開了
然後變成遺產要給小孩的話
那可能稅務的這個問題就會更多
那雖然有一個1333萬的這個免稅額
但超過的部分
在5000多萬以下
大概就是10%
那超過15%
到達一億兩千多萬以上的話
就會變20%
那我們一般來說
說房產其實超過兩三千萬很容易
所以甚至有些很容易就超過五千萬
所以如果我們可以在有能力的時候
先幫小孩存第一桶金
每一年有逐步的撥一些金錢
去幫小孩做這個股票投資
或者是不同資產的投資方式都可以
會避免掉這個以後遺產的這個費用的產生
謝謝陳月如教授今天帶我們重新思考
為什麼退休規劃一定要提早開始
希望今天的內容可以讓正在為未來感到不安的你
多一點方向也多一點安心
最後喜歡我們的影片也不要忘記
訂閱按贊開啟小鈴鐺哦
我們下集再見
拜拜